i like batman because he's a he's mortal  i don't i don't like batman  it's a shame that they never made the  real superhero man of steel dude  superman [ __ ] superman he's bruce  wayne his parents got murdered when he  was young he has a [ __ ] mansion and  he's got an english butler and he  [ __ ] it's like okay spiderman hey  don't [ __ ] believe i'm having this  argument there is no [ __ ] way they  will ever make a [ __ ] superman movie  as good as the one is that one dude did  with the joker  i know better villains who the [ __ ] he's  got that bald [ __ ] who looks like me lex  luthor that's his big [ __ ] nemesis a  guy dude  he's got the [ __ ] riddler he's got  the uh the show pony i don't know where  they [ __ ] fight whatever and even  made a superman movie is my point they  have made superman movies they stink  they do yet simultaneously they can  write all these great movies for the  other one the character stinks paul